salut c'est rod salut c'est Aurélie et
ben en fait avant on habitait à
Saint-Malo dans un 45 mètres carrés et
maintenant on habite à
Saint-Georges-de-Reintembault dans un
1800 mètres carrés donc ben venez mener
donc on a commencé la destruction des
murs au lendemain de Noël je savais pas
quoi faire au lendemain de Noël je me
suis bah tiens je vais commencer à faire
des travaux donc ici
petit séjour petit séjour de 57 mètres
carrés petit par rapport au bâtiment et
ici c'est l'ancienne salle de chimie
physique et donc les trois premiers
carreaux ça sera la cuisine dinatoire et
les deux autres carreaux ça sera
toilettes salle de bain en fait ce 1800
m² que vous voyez en fait c'était un
ancien collège qui s'appelait le bocage
qui a eu une activité très courte de
1974 à 1994
s'il y a bien un truc que le confinement
nous a appris c'est que tout était
possible je pense que si tu ne changes
pas de vie maintenant tu changeras
jamais